pour tous ceux qui apprécient le
dimanche de visiter certains points
certains se voir ils ont la possibilité
la possibilité maintenant de pouvoir
rouler autant qu'ils veulent
même en n'étant pas de grands sportifs
et donc de pouvoir se reposer au moment
le désert il recharger les batteries on
va dire on les trouvera au concours
lépine en suivant première apparition du
génie des petits inventeurs cette
bicyclette ou des leviers sans point
mort en place le classique pédalier rien
n'a changé pour le reste où
l'imagination créatrice le dispute à la
fantaisie la plus réaliste le clignotant
rétractable pour vélomoteur par exemple
ou encore l'auto pédales d'un maniement
extrêmement commode et qui réhabilite
loto à pédales de nos enfants le pétrole
iovino muni d'un ressort il se détend
dans les côtes est en berne et
affirme-t-on l'ascension sans fatigue
ce vélo plat de tout repos lui aussi du
moins en apparence
un bricoleur ingénieux vient en effet de
mettre au point l'adaptation aux
populaires vélos de trois éléments de
réaction placé à l'arrière
importe quel tocard peux t'attendre 45 à
leurs vestiges des géants de la route
que vaincue 2000
en ces temps de crise d'essence on
regardera d'un bon oeil
l'apparition de la moto dépliante toutes
consacrées à cette économie qui paie les
solides fortune car il lui faut peu
d'essence veut devenu eu de place